not go gently into that good night old
age should burn and rave at close of day
rage rage against the dying of the light
the light meant everything to Gwyn the
before light he was nothing imagine
being an aimless member of some
primitive congregation barely scraping
by in a harsh dark world then you come
across a most glorious sight light and
by that light he'd find a soul not just
any soul but the most powerful soul one
that carries with it the power know the
responsibility to lift your race out of
the shadows onto the surface where the
dragons dwell Gwyn did not win this
first war overnight we forget this but
during the age of ancients there was
still time for the Lords to rise
civilizations were built alliances were
forged loyal Knights were appointed and
betrayers were born for after disparity
came creatures that were not born equal
creatures like safe who lived without
the immortal stone scales of his
brethren with his mortality came a
desperation ambition a jealousy things
the stone dragons never had and could
never understand and so with their
secrets betrayed by the pale Drake the
Dragons homes were burned to ash the
scales were pierced by lightning and
their flesh was exposed to disease the
war was won and Gwyn could have
eliminated safe here but he chose not to
instead he did just the opposite he
granted safe a piece of his very own
soul he elevated him to the peerage he
granted him dukedom and also the hand of
his daughter
Guinevere with whom he could saya royal
children
honouring safe like this ended up
costing Gwyn his closest battle
compatriot Havel the rock who harbored
this deep hatred against the scaleless
dragon Havel
is not found in game but deep within an
Orlando behind an illusionary wall and
protected by a mimic are his armaments
alongside the occult weaponry designed
to kill a God from this we can guess
that Havel nursed this resentment for
Gwyn though it seems he never acted on
it at this time after all
Gwyn was surrounded by his entourage of
knights many of them wistfully craving
this return to the combat that had once
given them purpose Gwyn would repeat
this behavior throughout the age of fire
keeping his friends close and his
enemies even closer for fire was at its
peak and the whole world was charmed by
its brilliance good men the last wave by
crying how bright their frail deeds
might have danced in a Green Bay rage
rage against the dying of the light
tanita Gwyn permitted a quiet domain for
all of the deceased and in return Neto
never did spread death to the gods
over in izalith the which was tolerated
despite spawning her creatures of chaos
but there was a fourth Lord one that I
didn't mention when talking about the
dragon wars but one who took part in
them just the same the furtive pygmy
race and their descendants
the pygmy Lords squirreling away a soul
of dark represented the most significant
threat to Gwynn's age of fire so what do
you think Gwyn did exterminate them no
instead Gwyn indebted them with the
greatest gifts of all while the pygmy
Lords waited patiently for light to fade
Gwyn twisted their fate prop up this
tiny race bathed them in the glory of
the light blinds them with its
brilliance give them a crown a ringed
city his youngest daughter let them
indulge in bounty
and while they're still weak raise a
dragon to watch over them seal their
dark with fire and shackle them to
mortality let them spread across the
earth and forget their heritage their
accomplishments let the origins of
humanity be buried out of sight and out
of mind
so the pygmies were walled off safe in a
city that exists only at the end of the
world most of them stayed there forever
happily subservient to their princess
Fillion or who's very slumber was a
miracle that was designed to prevent
time from passing meanwhile humans the
pygmies ancestors had spread to the
outside world and out there they too
warmed themselves by fire however
unbeknownst to most of them this ran
counter to their true nature in the dark
there are no shadows but where fire
resides shadows twist and shrivel so
some members of the dark did sense that
something was wrong and they began to
RAM against their shackles first the Mad
King was born to the pygmies and he was
undying as the dark should be so he was
held in a dark room until the end of
time later
yet another pygmy Lord would go on to
spawn an abyss when he was unearthed in
all the seal and over time even mankind
turned into monsters
this hollowing process that unfairly
became attributed to their darkness
instead of the fire the branded them
though wise men at their end know dark
is right because their words had forked
no lightning they do not go gentle into
that good night
Quinn's favorite tool of control was the
church something he had used to great
effect already in the ring city and he
would use it again now to indoctrinate
the people of the wider world Gwyn the
White was their deity of worship and
Lloyd the gray was at its head acting as
a sort of intermediary between gods and
humans they framed undeath as a terrible
sin and so the undead became the
subjects of undead hunts led by cleric
Knights charged to cleanse the unholy
and if such a cleric god forbid
actually became undead themselves then
there was a solution to that to such
ironically cursed humans were shipped
off to Lordran and given a new holy
mission retrieved the right of kindling
from the deadly catacombs and if you
should fail well so what
Gwyn had basically dressed up exile for
his undead clerics but one man whose
exile he did not spin for once was the
banishment of his firstborn son the
nameless king God of War and leader of
the sunlight covenant had his godhood
rescinded after it was discovered that
he was fraternizing with dragons this
was something he covered up in addition
it seems like quints captain of the
guard on Steam went on to leave his post
in favor of the nameless king and so -
it appears did Havel who's Knights arise
in the nameless Kings defense at arch
dragon peak a war had been fought in the
name of disparity yet how righteous
truly was their war against the ancient
unchanging everlasting dragons when Gwyn
himself refused to cede to the natural
order
but Gwynn's manipulation would not last
for the
King was just a crack in the dam and the
wall was set to burst wild men who
caught and sang the Sun in flight and
learn too late they grieved it on its
way do not go gentle into that good
night many alliances broke seemingly all
at once gravelord nito had become
increasingly reclusive and the rite of
kindling had been lost within his domain
izalith had defiled flame and Gwynn's
war against her demons had weakened his
armies seif was trending towards madness
the way of white had begun to worship
lloyd instead and there were even
whispers that calf one of the primordial
serpents had begun speaking the truth
about the pygmy Lords Gwynn's light was
waning illusions could keep it alive no
longer and some people waited for a Dark
Lord to be born amongst humans was calf
rights was he fighting against the
inevitable had he found the wrong soul
no he was Lord Gwyn Auguste magnificence
and if he was not yet worthy of worship
then it was because he had not yet made
a great enough sacrifice so Gwyn would
link the fire leave a mark perform the
miracle that was so great a sacrifice so
complete that it would bring the world
back from the brink of darkness and it
worked well too well
win was consumed and with his dying
breath
utterly defied disparity the world
became cursed and from this point on
every time an age of fire dwindled the
souls of Lords would flourish anew so
that it could all play out again the
timeline of fire had warped it had
turned from a straight-line linked into
a circle becoming this wall containing
the rightful age of dark until the end
of time eventually as the world burned
out over
and over again ash itself would arise a
new being created from a thousand
failures who had tried to link the fire
over the years but ash did not belong in
this world and honestly they had more in
common with the beings of the painted
world where all of fiers discarded
things resigned so they fought for a new
purpose to reunite the Dark Soul and to
paint a new world with it so that they
could escape the ashen wasteland that
Gwyn had created and so far away at the
very end of the world one of the first
victims of the curse slave night Gale
hallowed beyond belief also sacrificed
himself for a new world and he did not
go gentle into that good night grave men
near death who see with blinding sight
blind eyes could blaze like meteors and
be gay rage rage against the dying of
the light and you my father
there on the sad height curse bless me
now with your fierce tears I pray do not
go gentle into that good night rage rage
[Music]
against the dying of the light
if you're watching this video in the
first week of its release then we have a
limited edition print of our new merge
design now available below in the
description this time it's inspired by
both Dark Souls and Eldon ring and it's
a new collaboration between myself and
ceebot so Eldon ring is now said to be a
sort of spiritual successor to Dark
Souls and just so I wanted to design a
piece that links the two together this
is fate
it's this ink styled Knight with bright
red hair that's inspired by olden rings
designs and he's reaching for a flaming
sword that's inspired by Dark Souls the
red hair part of the design is the
limited edition variant and it's only
available for the coming week and then
never again so check it out next week's
video is going to be on Eldon ring so
stay tuned for that there's been no news
about this game for months now and I
think it's about time we start making up
our own Eldon ring content thank you for
watching and I hope you all enjoyed this
prepare to cry and I'll see you all next
time